Speaker 1: All right. Real quick, I don't want
to spend a lot of time on cat turd. This isn't
really a program where cat turd is a big thing.
But Donald Trump hit an absolute rock bottom,
rock bottom new low posting cat turd polls to
truth, social censure. I managed to get through
that mostly without laughing. Yes. Donald Trump in
an act of. Aspiration to show how well he is doing
against Ron DeSantis in the Republican primary.
Over the weekend posted a new poll just out. And
when you look closely, you realize that the poll
is from the cat. The poll is from the cat turd
Twitter Twitter account. This is a an account that
pushes right wing nonsense. It isn't a poll. It's
quite literally just like a Twitter survey where
a couple hundred thousand followers of cat turd
voted and Trump did have 69% of the vote compared
to Ron DeSantis is 24. And I don't know that
there's really that much commentary to do here
other than Trump is posting captured in the middle
of the night is not typically the or actually this
one was in the afternoon to be completely clear.
It's not typically what you would expect from
a former president. Cat turd is not big among
Obama cat turd, notably not big among George
W Bush, but Trump posting cat turd. And it's
all getting very sad and very, very tragic if
if I'm totally up front with you. All right.
Let's take a quick break. We're going to get to
book banning. We're going to get to the regrowth
of of toes through prayer and lots of other
important things after this very short break.